[موسيقى]
متسرب من المدرسه محتال منحرف يبتز
الاقليات العرقيه وربما مشروع مجرما
يتعاطى المخدرات هكذا كان يمكن ان تكون
حياه مارك والبردج الذي انتشالته الموسيقى
من عالم الاجرام الى هوليود فما قصه ولد
عام
1971 في بوسطن كانت والدته ممرضه ووليده
سائقه توصيل وهو الاصغر بين تسعه اطفال
انفصل والده وهو في الحاديه عشر ما اثر
على سلوكه بشكل كبير فترك المدرسه
الثانويه واتجاه نحو حياه الجريمه البسيطه
والمخدرات
في سن السادسه عشر ادين بمحاوله السطو على
شخصين من الاقليات وسجن 50 يوما ولكن
تاهيله داخل السجن ساعده ليغير سلوكه بعد
سجن انضم مارك بمساعده اخيه الاكبر دوني
الى فرقه ماركي مارك وبانكي بانش للهيبوب
كمغني راب وعلى الرغم من ضعف قدرته على
الغناء كانت حركاته الراقصه ولياقته
البدنيه سببا في نجاحه كتب دنيا بعض
الاغاني لمبارك وجمع مجموعه موسيقيين
ليصدر البومه الاول ميوزك فور ذا بيبول
الذي حقق نجاح ساحقا لم تطل مسيره مارك
الغنائيه في البومه الثاني يوجات ابليس لم
يلقى النجاح ذاته ورغم نجاحه بالظهور في
الاعلانات التجاريه كعارض ازياء لكنه
غالبا ما تورط في الفضاء كما عان مره اخرى
من مشكلات قانونيه كالاعتداء على حارس امن
خلى مارك علق به الموسيقي ماركي مارك وقرر
تحول للتمثيل فظهر اول مره بفيلم رينيسانس
مان عام
1994 لكن الجمهور لم يتقبل من مغني الراب
ان يصبح ممثلا لكنه استمر وظهر مره اخرى
بفيلم ذا باسكت بول داينويس ونال ثناء
عليه على عكس سابقه ما سمح له بالحصول على
ادوار اخرى لاحقا مع كل فيلم جديد كان
مارك يحقق نجاحات غير مسبوقه حيث يوجد في
رصيده 64 فيلما على الاقل خلال مسيره حصاد
فيها ايضا مجموعه من الجوائز خصوصا بعد
نجاحه في الاداء الكوميدي في فيلم تيد عام
2013 حيث حصل على جائزه فيلم اختيار
النقاط كما حصل عن ادائه في فيلم ذا فايتر
على جائزه ام تي فيريشن واحرز جائزه
الجمعيه 100 لنقاد السينما لافضل ممثل
مساعد مرتين وغيرها من الجوائز الفنيه كما
تم ترشيحه لاكثر من 50 جائزه بما في ذلك
جائزتا الاوسكار وجائزه جولدن جلوب وسبعه
جوائز برايم تايم انمي كممارك بالانتاج
التنفيذي لمسلسلات تليفزيونيه مثل بورد
2010 وانتريتمان 2008
وانتراج 2004 ماركل الذي كان من الممكن ان
يصبح مجرما اليوم هو واحد من اكثر
الفنانين نجاحا وثراء ايضا حيث يمتلك ثروه
تقدر ب 400 مليون دولار
[موسيقى]